[Musica]
se io mi domandasse
avete mai comunicato con un alieno
ve lo chiedo perché è molto vicino a
quello che sto cercando di fare
ma andiamo con ordine
vi racconto di me io sono in una zona
del monferrato
collinosa
è un luogo particolare si percepisce che
ha un'anima
passeggiando tra i filari ordinati dalle
vigne
quello che gli antichi chiamavano il
genius loci che rispettavano e
veneravano
mi ricordo che un pomeriggio sono andato
nella vigna del vicino con dei cavi di
rame gli ho infilati nel terreno e
giocavo a spiare quello che si dicevano
le viti
io non è che andasse da miracolosa kyoto
mi portavo i cavi di rame
motori elettrici marchingegni di ogni
tipo
poi crescendo mi sono interessato alla
fisica all'elettronica all'esplorazione
spaziale e sono sempre stato un po alla
ricerca di un contatto con qualcosa di
così lontano
da essere definibile alieno
almeno nel senso dell'etimologia latina
diverso
parlo dell'alieno che arriva dal cielo
perché le iene già qua
vi parlo di un bosco
allora un bosco è composto da piante da
funghi
da li tieni da erbe da tutti gli animali
che lo abitano
immaginiamo un primo contatto un
incontro se voi poteste comunicare col
bosco che cosa gli chiede veste
ciao come ti chiami
oppure da dove vieni
forse la domanda giusta da poco e
sarebbe piuttosto come stai
sapere come sta un bosco importante
perché ci può dare delle informazioni su
come tutti gli organismi che lo
compongono si relazionano tra di loro
all'interno di questo ecosistema
piante funghi
organismi interessanti questi abitano se
ci pensate sul pianeta terra da molti
più milioni di anni di noi
quindi hanno sperimentato l'evoluzione
per un periodo di tempo maggiore
potremmo quasi dire che sono più evoluti
loro di noi anche se è difficile da
immaginare
dice piante funghi sono più sensibili ai
cambiamenti climatici
questo perché banalmente loro non
possono spostarsi e cercava il palo come
invece facciamo noi
gli esperti ci spiegano che piante
funghi affrontano l'imprevisto con la
collaborazione sono organismi
cooperativi di fatto è come se fossero
un organismo collettivo
ecco io credo che sia veramente
fondamentale
comunicare con l'intero organismo
collettivo e non soltanto con un
individuo un organismo che lo compone
e come si fa ci sono cinque fasi per
raggiungere questo questa comunicazione
punto 1 prendere contatto qua a pane
legge
nel 2018
una tempesta che si chiama vaia si
abbatte sulla valle di fiemme
con venti fino a 217 km orari
rovesciando piscine olimpioniche di
acqua dal cielo
alla fine saranno stati abbattuti 42
milioni di alberi in prevalenza abete
rosso che gli viene coltivato da
millenni
la gente del posto si rimbocca le
maniche e ripulisce risistema ma
soprattutto cerca un modo per capire
come sta al bosco dopo questo evento
più o meno nello stesso periodo un amico
collega che si chiama indrìo damaschi e
dell'università di bristol mi contatta e
mi propone un progetto folle di
comunicazione non convenzionale proprio
per cercare di capire come sta quel
bosco dopo l'impatto della tempesta
fantastico io accetto subito l'incarico
e quindi ci mettiamo gli scarponi
visitiamo questo luogo
respiriamo i suoi odori
e sentiamo la sua anima
come si fa l'anima di un bosco
punto 2
l'ascolto
bisogna ascoltare
e senza presunzione
che ci vuole anche tanta tecnologia
non è facile mestiere
immaginate che ci siano a 12 gradi sotto
zero che voi dobbiate usare le mani che
siano congelate
immaginate che vi manca il fiato perché
siete a 2000 metri di quota
o che vi venga sete versate l'acqua
dentro la tazza e questa si congela
istantaneamente
però si fa adesso in questo momento ci
sono
un'infrastruttura intera con centinaia
di metri di cavo per applicazioni audio
ad alta fedeltà
c'è una centralina climatica ci sono dei
dispositivi elettronici che raccolgono
campionando dati migliaia di dati al
secondo e li inviano via radio
e tutta questa infrastruttura funziona
con l'energia del sole
facciamo con queste cose noi li
misuriamo il bio potenziale elettrico
delle piante e dei funghi
vi ricordate i cavi nella vigna di
quando ero bambino ho recuperato quella
passione
questo bio potenziale ci dà delle
informazioni istante per istante
secondo per secondo su come sta il bosco
questi azioni come ci possiamo
relazionare come le possiamo
decodificare
terzo punto il linguaggio
quelle che vedete sono delle tracce
di un segnale di un intelligenza
superiore più grande della nostra
se facciamo due conti sulla complessità
che ha generato queste curve
pittura più complessa di qualsiasi
intelligenza artificiale sia mai stata
prodotta
ma è altrettanto difficile capirci
qualcosa
c'è bisogno di un alfabeto di simboli
di un vocabolario
per potere poi dialogare
e questa cosa è molto importante noi
vogliamo dialogare con l'intero super
organismo che abita a paneveggio non
sono tanto con una pianta o un fungo
questo è già stato fatto non ci
interessa i laboratori ad altre persone
no noi vogliamo dialogare con tutto
questo ecosistema
e come si fa a dialogare
beh
ma estremamente complesso
c'è bisogno di molte competenze e quindi
di una pratica un protocollo che si
adotta in progetti come questo che si
chiama open science quarto punto copin
science possiamo tradurre con la scienza
libera
vuol dire che noi mettiamo a
disposizione tutte le informazioni che
abbiamo raccolto
affinché
persone esperte
lavorino su questi dati queste
informazioni e ci aiutino quindi a
decodificare
è perché è complicato bisogna saperne un
po di tutto di entropia di
trasformazione funzionali di algoritmica
di reti di fisiologia vegetale di
risonanza stocastica
c'è bisogno di un elettronico che
sviluppi dispositivi che ci servono c'è
bisogno di un fisico teorico che ci
fornisca i modelli predittivi c'è
bisogno di un botanico che ci dica come
funziona una pianta di un micologo che
ci indichi quale specie di fungo andare
a cercare
c'è bisogno di un linguista che ci
insegni quali sono le caratteristiche di
un linguaggio
tutto questo
con l'obiettivo
ripeto di dialogare con il super
organismo
punto 5 il dialogo
e qua altra idea folle
quella di utilizzare il gioco
il gioco è un meccanismo naturale di
apprendimento
e certo che non possiamo giocare a
scacchi con il bosco di paneveggio c'è
bisogno di un gioco che abbia delle
regole molto semplici addirittura quasi
banali
abbiamo pensato al go
forse qualcuno di voi ne ha sentito
parlare in relazione proprio all
intelligenza artificiale
è un gioco millenario simile alla dama
che ha fondamentalmente due regole
quindi è semplice da implementare
ecco noi vogliamo giocare con
l'ecosistema di paneveggio una partita
di golf
e questa cosa quando la faccia ma se
tutto va bene nel 2024
quindi ricapitolando i punti sono
prendere contatto
ascoltare con gentilezza e senza
presunzione
utilizzare un linguaggio che quello che
qando di definire oggi
avvalersi dell'open science cioè tanti
esperti lavorano insieme
con l'obiettivo
del dialogo
all intero sistema
super organismo
che è molto di più della somma delle sue
semplici parti
insomma l'avrete capito questo è un
progetto
molto complesso e in progetti così
complessi c'è bisogno del supporto di
molte persone
questo conto alla rovescia
quando sarà scaduto
sarà il momento in cui noi metteremo a
disposizione tutti i dati che avremmo
raccolto fino ad allora per chiunque
stia ora ascoltando queste parole e
abbia voglia di scaricarsi il materiale
e lavorare aiutandoci ad interpretare i
dati
in progetti così non necessariamente si
cerca un esperto uno scienziato
piuttosto un esperto di altra cosa
magari un artista musicista
se vi ricordate incontri ravvicinati del
terzo tipo
per comunicare con gli alieni si
utilizzava la musica
come meccanismo
dobbiamo imparare da piante funghi a
essere più noi
ecosistema superorganismo e meno
individui
di certo vi posso promettere che ci sarà
moltissimo da sperimentare e da imparare
potremmo ad esempio imparare a riparare
i danni fatti
potremmo imparare
da piante funghi
una nuova prospettiva un nuovo punto di
vista loro
una nuova logica
una nuova emotività
che non è mai stato
né descritta
grazie
[Applauso]